Since the beginning of the COVID-19 pandemic, misinformation has often seemed to spread as fast as a virus itself. Millions of people have disregarded scientists' advice on vaccines and masks and tried unproven and potentially unsafe treatments. It's the latest, but far from the only example of science denial and of how public doubt and disbelief of science can harm people's health and the health of the planet. Science has become polarized and politicized, but science denial crosses party lines. On hot-button topics such as vaccines, climate change, and genetically modified foods, people across the political spectrum are susceptible to the psychological forces that lead them to disbelieve what scientists are telling them and to seek out information that confirms
自新冠疫情爆发以来，错误信息似乎传播得和病毒一样快。数百万人无视科学家关于疫苗和口罩的建议，转而尝试未经证实且可能不安全的疗法。这是科学否认主义的最新例证，但绝非唯一。公众对科学的怀疑和不信任会损害人们的健康以及地球的健康。科学已经变得两极分化和政治化，但科学否认主义跨越了党派界限。在疫苗、气候变化和转基因食品等热门话题上，整个政治光谱中的人们都容易受到心理力量的影响，导致他们不相信科学家所说的话，并寻求那些能够证实
rather than challenges their biases. So what are these psychological forces? Why do people doubt and deny scientific findings? Is science denial worse now than it's ever been? Does the American public trust scientists or look upon them with suspicion? How have the Internet and social media magnified science skepticism. And what can scientists, science communicators, and science educators do to help people gain a more accurate understanding of how science works. Welcome to speaking of psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. We have two guests today who are co-authors of a new book called Science Denial, Why It Happens and What to Do About It, Published
而不是挑战他们偏见的信息。那么，这些心理力量是什么？为什么人们会怀疑和否认科学发现？科学否认主义现在比以往任何时候都更严重吗？美国公众是信任科学家，还是对他们持怀疑态度？互联网和社交媒体是如何放大科学怀疑论的？科学家、科学传播者和科学教育者能做些什么来帮助人们更准确地理解科学是如何运作的？欢迎收听美国心理学会的旗舰播客《心理学谈话》，该节目探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。今天我们邀请了两位嘉宾，她们是一本名为《科学否认：为何发生以及如何应对》的新书的合著者，该书由牛津大学出版社于
in July by Oxford University Press. First is Dr. Gail Sinatra, a professor of psychology and education at the University of Southern California's Rossier School of Education. Dr. Sinatra's recent research focuses on understanding the role that motivation and emotion play in teaching and learning about controversial science topics such as evolution and climate change. She's a fellow of APA's Division of Educational Psychology and is chair of the association's current task force on climate change. We're also joined by Dr. Barbara Hofer, a professor emerita of psychology at Middlebury College in Vermont. Dr. Hofer studies psychological aspects of the public understanding of science, including what's called epistemic cognition, or how people develop their beliefs about
7月出版。第一位是南加州大学罗西尔教育学院的心理学与教育学教授盖尔·西纳特博士。西纳特博士近期的研究重点是理解动机和情绪在进化论和气候变化等争议性科学话题的教学与学习中所扮演的角色。她是美国心理学会教育心理学分会的成员，也是该协会当前气候变化特别工作组的主席。另一位嘉宾是佛蒙特州米德尔伯里学院的心理学荣誉退休教授芭芭拉·霍弗博士。霍弗博士研究公众理解科学的心理层面，包括所谓的认知认识论，即人们如何发展出关于
knowledge and knowing, as well as psychological explanations for science denial, doubt, and resistance. She's also an APA fellow. Thank you both for joining us today to talk about this timely topic. Thank you. Thank you for having us. So let's start with the question I posed in my introduction. Is science denial worse now than it's ever been? You point out in the book that it has a long history going back at least to Galileo, and you've both been studying this topic for many years. Does science denial seem more prevalent to you now than when you started doing this research? Yeah, I think it's fascinating for us to think about when we began the book and what has happened since then. And I think a couple things stand out to us. One is that science denial is so amplifying. by social media. And that's new. Certainly, that wasn't the case for many of the other periods of science denial that we know about. But it's so amplified in the way that social media sends it out and it travels around the world so rapidly that the disinformation problem is enormous. But the other thing for us is that it is now deadly. There is no other time in history that we can think about
知识和认知的信念，以及对科学否认、怀疑和抵触的心理学解释。她也是美国心理学会的成员。感谢两位今天加入我们，共同探讨这个及时的话题。谢谢。谢谢邀请我们。那么，让我们从我在介绍中提出的问题开始。科学否认主义现在比以往任何时候都更严重吗？你们在书中指出，它有着悠久的历史，至少可以追溯到伽利略时代，而且你们两位研究这个课题已经很多年了。与你们刚开始做这项研究时相比，科学否认主义现在看起来更普遍了吗？是的，我认为回顾我们开始写这本书的时候以及之后发生的事情，是非常引人入胜的。我们认为有几点很突出。首先，科学否认主义被社交媒体极大地放大了。这是新的现象。当然，在我们所知的科学否认主义的其他时期，情况并非如此。但它在社交媒体的传播方式下被如此放大，以至于它在全球范围内迅速传播，导致虚假信息问题变得极其严重。但对我们来说，另一件事是它现在是致命的。我们想不出历史上还有什么其他时期
science denial causing so many deaths. I mean, the people who are dead. I mean, the people who are denying to the grave right now. We have so many examples of people who are on ventilators and who are still resisting the fact that it could possibly be COVID because they believe it's a hoax. That's deeply, deeply troubling. And it has impeded our progress in dealing with a pandemic as well as with climate change. We really worry about the way that this has stopped us from getting the solutions we need to both of those problems as well as many others. Dr. Sanatra, do you agree? Is it worse today because of social media? Well, there's no doubt that we are in our information bubbles. And if you are getting disinformation
科学否认主义导致了如此多的死亡。我是说，那些死去的人。我是说，那些现在还在否认直到临终的人。我们有太多例子，人们戴着呼吸机，却仍然拒绝承认这可能是新冠病毒，因为他们认为这是一个骗局。这非常、非常令人不安。它阻碍了我们在应对疫情以及气候变化方面的进展。我们真的很担心这种现象阻止了我们获得解决这两个问题以及许多其他问题所需的方案。西纳特博士，你同意吗？因为社交媒体，现在情况更糟了吗？嗯，毫无疑问，我们正处于信息茧房中。如果你因为社交媒体平台使用的算法而
in your information bubble due to the algorithms that the social media platforms use, then it's possible that you are being inundated with dis and misinformation. And that is what has amplified this. Back before we had the internet, you would probably talk to you. your neighbors. You'd probably talk to your community or church members or school board members, and you might all have different points of view and you might hear all these different points of you. But now we live in like-minded communities and we're in like-minded social media and online news media bubbles. And you're not hearing different points of view that much. And so people aren't getting the pushback against the dis and misinformation that perhaps they used to get
在你的信息茧房中接收虚假信息，那么你很可能正被错误信息和虚假信息所淹没。这就是放大这一现象的原因。在互联网出现之前，你可能会和邻居交谈。你可能会和社区、教会成员或学校董事会成员交谈，你们可能都有不同的观点，也可能会听到所有这些不同的观点。但现在我们生活在志同道合的社区中，处于志同道合的社交媒体和在线新闻媒体的茧房中。你听不到太多不同的观点。因此，人们没有得到像过去那样对错误信息和虚假信息的反驳
in the past. And that is what has amplified this phenomenon. And you can think about algorithms as just a basic organizing principle of digital life. And so when you like something, it's going to send you more of what you like. That's what happens on Facebook. And yet, most people are not even really aware of how that works. You know, algorithms are proprietary information owned by Google or or whoever it is, we don't know exactly how they're feeding us information. And many people think that other people are seeing exactly what they're seeing. They don't realize they're living in an echo chamber. They don't realize how the filter bubbles are sending them back an amplification of what they've already thought about and believed. So on the one hand, we have all this access to information,
在过去。这就是放大这一现象的原因。你可以把算法看作数字生活的基本组织原则。所以当你喜欢某样东西时，它会给你推送更多你喜欢的东西。这就是Facebook上发生的事情。然而，大多数人甚至并不真正了解它是如何运作的。你知道，算法是谷歌或任何其他公司拥有的专有信息，我们并不确切知道它们是如何向我们推送信息的。许多人认为别人看到的和他们看到的一模一样。他们没有意识到自己生活在回声室里。他们没有意识到过滤气泡是如何将他们已经思考和相信的东西放大后反馈给他们的。所以一方面，我们拥有所有这些获取信息的渠道，
so potentially we could be seeing a lot of good things. But all you have to do is click on one wacko thing and the next thing you know, you're getting more misinformation, more stuff that has really not been scientifically tested. That's what you're saying. Yes, we thought the internet would democratize information access and in some ways it has done that, but it's also democratized dis and misinformation and propaganda. And that is creating these information bubbles and people living within psychological states of confusion, doubt, denial, and science resistance. You know, some of the Pew Research that's gone on this has even advocated for algorithmic literacy. It's been so disturbing how few people really understand what's being fed back to them.
因此我们本可以看到很多好的东西。但你只需要点击一个疯狂的东西，接下来你就会收到更多的错误信息，更多真正没有经过科学验证的东西。这就是你所说的。是的，我们曾以为互联网会使信息获取民主化，在某些方面它确实做到了，但它也使错误信息、虚假信息和宣传民主化了。这正在创造这些信息茧房，人们生活在困惑、怀疑、否认和科学抵触的心理状态中。你知道，皮尤研究中心进行的一些研究甚至提倡算法素养。很少有人真正理解反馈给他们的内容，这非常令人不安。
And I've done some studies where students have, I've had students search for various topics that we know are controversial. And I've had some of the students in my lab pretend, for example, to be an elementary school kid who wants to know if dinosaurs lived at the same time as humans. A pretty basic question. And yet they were shocked to find out that seven out of the top 10 websites that came back to them confirmed that that was the case. Because there are a number of organizations like the Creation Museum that have given all the money to figure out how to get their results to come up really high.
我做过一些研究，让学生搜索我们知道有争议的各种主题。我让实验室里的一些学生假装，例如，是一个想知道恐龙是否与人类生活在同一时期的小学生。一个非常基本的问题。然而，他们惊讶地发现，返回给他们的前10个网站中，有7个证实了这一点。因为有很多像创造博物馆这样的组织，投入了所有资金来研究如何让他们的结果排在非常靠前的位置。
And these students were saying to me, we always thought, and these are college students. We thought that the top 10 hits were somehow verified, reliable, trustworthy. Those are not factors that filter into Google at all. That is just not how it works. So people've learned how to game the system, even if they don't know exactly how the algorithms work, they know how to play the game in order to get you to see that. And then there are websites like procon.org that they thought were really reliable because it's an organizational site.
这些学生对我说，我们一直认为，而且这些是大学生。我们认为前10个搜索结果在某种程度上是经过验证的、可靠的、值得信赖的。这些根本不是谷歌过滤的因素。事情根本不是那样运作的。所以人们学会了如何操纵系统，即使他们不知道算法到底是如何工作的，他们也知道如何玩这个游戏，让你看到这些内容。然后还有像procon.org这样的网站，他们认为这些网站非常可靠，因为这是一个组织网站。
And yet when you go on there, they'll give you 10 reasons pro, 10 reasons con for any topic, whether that is climate change, for example. You can find 10 reasons why, yes, maybe it's human caused and 10 reasons why it might not. So it's not hard to understand why people are having a really hard time ferreting out what might be true, valid, reliable, et cetera. Dr. Sanatra, let me ask you this. In the book you write about some of the problems with the way that we teach science in K through 12, What are we doing wrong and what needs to change about the way we teach children science?
然而当你上去时，他们会给你提供任何主题的10个赞成理由和10个反对理由，比如气候变化。你可以找到10个理由说明，是的，这可能是人为造成的，也有10个理由说明可能不是。所以不难理解为什么人们在辨别什么是真实的、有效的、可靠的等方面感到非常困难。西纳特博士，让我问你这个问题。在书中，你写到了我们在K-12阶段教授科学方式存在的一些问题。我们做错了什么？在教授儿童科学的方式上需要改变什么？
Well, that's a great question, Kim. Traditionally, science was taught as a collection of facts in your textbook. And that's been changing, but needs to change even more. The next generation science standards, which are the recommended standards for teaching science in K through 12, recommend teaching science as not a collection of facts, but as a process. So they talk about how scientists know and teaching students to ask and answer their own questions. These are scientific practices. And this is a much more productive way to teach science.
嗯，这是一个很好的问题，金。传统上，科学被当作教科书中的事实集合来教授。这种情况正在改变，但还需要更多地改变。《下一代科学标准》，即K-12科学教学的推荐标准，建议将科学教学不仅作为事实的集合，而是作为一个过程。所以他们谈论科学家是如何认知的，并教学生提出并回答他们自己的问题。这些是科学实践。这是一种更有效的科学教学方式。
Unfortunately, only a handful of states have adopted the next generation science standards. As you know, education standards are locally adopted. there's not a national standard. So these standards are recommended, but not fully adopted by all states. But we would definitely say teaching science as a process, engaging students in that process, and having them ask and answer their own questions is a much better approach to teaching science. And I think the other thing we talk about in the book is that we really think that students ought to be more exposed to some of the underlying assumptions of science as well. So, for example, scientists talk about tentativeness.
不幸的是，只有少数几个州采用了《下一代科学标准》。如你所知，教育标准是地方采用的，没有国家标准。所以这些标准是推荐的，但并没有被所有州完全采用。但我们肯定会说，将科学作为一种过程来教授，让学生参与到这个过程中，并让他们提出并回答自己的问题，是更好的科学教学方法。我认为我们在书中谈到的另一件事是，我们真的认为学生应该更多地接触科学的一些基本假设。例如，科学家谈论暂定性。
We do that in psychology. You know, we don't say we prove something. We say we provided support for it, but more studies are needed. When the lay public hears that, if they are not scientifically literate, they have a really hard time. They expect certainty. And I think what we've seen with what is a novel coronavirus, which means we've never seen it before, is that scientists were learning as we went along. Remember when we were all wiping down our groceries and we were concerned about how the disease was spreading? Because scientists didn't know yet. And yet people think that's flip-flopping. They think, wait a minute, they wanted us to wipe down our groceries and now they think we need to wear mask, but they didn't think we needed to wear mask back at the beginning. And they think that this is a problem with science. And in fact, this is how science works. They chip away at the problem and they've done it very quickly in this case. And yet people have been impatient with how things have changed and they don't. don't understand it. There was a lovely piece in the New York Times last week about the American
我们在心理学中就是这样做的。你知道，我们不说我们证明了什么。我们说我们为它提供了支持，但还需要更多的研究。当普通大众听到这些时，如果他们不具备科学素养，他们会感到非常困难。他们期望确定性。我认为我们从所谓的新型冠状病毒中看到的是，这意味着我们以前从未见过它，科学家们是在边做边学。还记得我们都在擦拭杂货，担心疾病是如何传播的吗？因为科学家当时还不知道。然而人们认为这是出尔反尔。他们认为，等一下，他们让我们擦拭杂货，现在他们认为我们需要戴口罩，但他们一开始并不认为我们需要戴口罩。他们认为这是科学的问题。事实上，这就是科学的运作方式。他们一点一点地解决问题，在这种情况下他们做得非常快。然而人们对事情的变化感到不耐烦，他们不理解。上周《纽约时报》有一篇很棒的文章，关于美国
public getting a crash course in scientific uncertainty and that this is a crisis of scientific literacy, that they don't understand the average person in this country how it is that scientists make these claims and what they mean when they say this is tentative and we're continuing to discover and explore. Do you have advice for scientists to help them communicate their work in a way that would help the public better understand the situation? I mean, when you talk about a theory, people think that means that it's not been decided yet. But that's not what a theory means in science, right? Oh, yeah, I want to jump in on that one because I've actually done research on this with students thinking about evolution. And so, and these were really bright
公众正在接受科学不确定性的速成课程，这是一场科学素养危机，这个国家的普通人并不理解科学家是如何提出这些主张的，以及当他们说这是暂定的，我们正在继续发现和探索时，他们是什么意思。你对科学家有什么建议，帮助他们以一种能帮助公众更好地理解情况的方式交流他们的工作吗？我的意思是，当你谈论一个理论时，人们认为这意味着它还没有定论。但科学中的理论不是这个意思，对吧？哦，是的，我想插一句，因为我实际上对此做过研究，学生们思考进化论。所以，这些是非常聪明的
college students. I'm going to say at the institution, the average SAT was 1440. And yet when I, when I ask them about evolutionary theory, what does theory mean in light of evolutionary theory? they almost every person, I think only 7% could define theory in scientific ways. The rest of them thought it was more like a hunch or a hypothesis. They really imagined the way I'd say, well, I have a theory about how I lost my keys, colloquially, they would think that's what evolutionary theory means. And so as a result, when I then asked them things like, should we be teaching intelligent design in schools, they would say, well, sure,
大学生。我想说在那个机构，SAT平均分是1440。然而当我问他们关于进化论的问题时，进化论中的理论意味着什么？几乎每个人，我想只有7%的人能用科学的方式定义理论。其余的人认为它更像是一种预感或假设。他们真的想象成我所说的那样，嗯，我有一个关于我如何丢失钥匙的理论，在口语中，他们会认为这就是进化论的意思。因此，当我问他们诸如我们是否应该在学校教授智能设计之类的问题时，他们会说，嗯，当然，
if there's more than one theory, we should teach both theories. And let the students decide. I mean, that's just deeply troubling. But also, scientists are not really, scientists are not really well trained, generally speaking, in communicating to the public. Scientists are trained in their discipline of science and to communicate that science to other scientists. That's what they do. They write geology articles in a geology and geoscience journal. But what we need to do is help science. as psychologists who understand interpersonal relationships and communications as well as anyone, we as psychologists need to help scientists understand their audience, understand how to communicate
如果有不止一个理论，我们应该教授两个理论。让学生自己决定。我的意思是，这非常令人不安。但科学家们通常并没有受过很好的训练，总的来说，在与公众交流方面。科学家受过科学学科的训练，并将该科学传达给其他科学家。这就是他们所做的。他们在地质学期刊上撰写地质学文章。但我们需要做的是帮助科学。作为既了解人际关系和沟通，又像任何人一样了解科学的心理学家，我们需要帮助科学家了解他们的受众，了解如何沟通
to their audience, and to appreciate words like uncertain and theory and what the general public thinks those mean. So when they present their findings, they need to be clear about those findings and use language that the public can understand, but also not be too tentative when the evidence is overwhelming. So we shouldn't be tentative about human contributions to climate change because the IPCC report that just came out a couple of weeks ago has overwhelming evidence from hundreds of scientists and thousands of studies that show our contributions. So we really need to not be tentative about that for the public to understand how close to certain we are about the causes of climate change. And to be fair, most scientists are not trained in communicating
给他们的受众，并理解像不确定和理论这样的词，以及普通大众认为这些词是什么意思。所以当他们展示他们的发现时，他们需要清楚这些发现，并使用公众能理解的语言，但在证据确凿时也不要太暂定。所以我们不应该对人类对气候变化的贡献持暂定态度，因为几周前发布的IPCC报告有来自数百名科学家和数千项研究的压倒性证据，显示了我们的贡献。所以我们真的需要不要对此持暂定态度，以便公众了解我们对气候变化原因的确定程度有多高。公平地说，大多数科学家并没有受过沟通训练
with the public, and many don't have the time. We also depend on science communicators, and we have been dismayed to see how that number is decreasing. So many newspapers 10, 15 years ago, had science sections and far fewer do now. And far fewer people are getting trained in how to communicate this information. And so a lot of it has to do with preparing science communicators to handle this well, training more science communicators, the translators, the people who can get out in the public and talk about the science in a knowledgeable, intelligible way. And of course, we all know their problems with headline writers. Most people don't write their own headlines. And we know what clickbait is now. We know that headlines. We know that headlines.
与公众交流，而且许多人没有时间。我们也依赖科学传播者，我们看到这个数字在减少，感到非常沮丧。10、15年前，许多报纸都有科学版块，而现在少多了。接受过如何传播这些信息培训的人也少多了。所以很多工作与准备科学传播者来很好地处理这个问题有关，培训更多的科学传播者，即翻译者，那些能够走进公众，以知识渊博、通俗易懂的方式谈论科学的人。当然，我们都知道标题撰写者存在的问题。大多数人并不自己写标题。我们现在知道什么是点击诱饵了。我们知道标题。我们知道标题。
get written in some way that grabs the public attention. Gail and I loved a piece that came out in Harvard Magazine a few weeks ago that was about, now I'm not going to remember the exact headline, but it was about eating chocolate early in the morning causes you to lose weight. I mean, this is so ludicrous. And yet when you read the actual study, there were only 19 people in the study and the authors, of course, said these are tentative conclusions and this will need to be replicated. And yet so often, people will read one study like that and grab onto it. But before you start spreading chocolate on your toast for breakfast, you really want a little more information. And I think that's hard for people to understand too. And then also they think scientists are
以某种方式编写，以吸引公众的注意力。盖尔和我喜欢几周前《哈佛杂志》上发表的一篇文章，关于，现在我不记得确切的标题了，但它是关于清晨吃巧克力会导致体重减轻。我的意思是，这太荒谬了。然而当你阅读实际的研究时，研究中只有19个人，作者当然说这些是暂定的结论，需要进行重复研究。然而，人们经常会阅读这样一项研究并抓住它。但在你开始在早餐吐司上涂巧克力之前，你真的需要更多信息。我认为这对人们来说也很难理解。然后他们也认为科学家是
flip-flopping again. Oh, they said this, then they said that. But they need to understand that what we're really looking for is what Gail talked about with the IPCC report. We're looking for a preponderance of information. We're looking for multiple studies that support something, not just one. I think we could do a better job also communicating a strength of science and psychological science is change. We don't treat people clinically the same way we did 50 years ago. The strength of a science is that it does change. And what we saw with coronavirus this past year is, is we saw the messy process of scientific change happening in real time, not opening a textbook and seeing facts, but the messy process of discovery and change in our thinking based on evidence.
又在出尔反尔了。哦，他们说了这个，然后又说了那个。但他们需要理解，我们真正寻找的是盖尔谈到的IPCC报告中的内容。我们正在寻找大量的信息。我们正在寻找支持某件事的多项研究，而不仅仅是一项。我认为我们也可以在传达科学的力量方面做得更好，心理科学的力量在于变化。我们不像50年前那样以同样的方式进行临床治疗。科学的力量在于它确实会改变。我们在过去一年中看到的冠状病毒，是我们实时看到了科学变化的混乱过程，而不是打开教科书看到事实，而是基于证据的发现和思维变化的混乱过程。
And that's something we need to help the public understand that that's a strength of science. We shouldn't be teaching the science of 50 years ago. Well, so getting back to the media, would you say that they're the biggest problem when it comes to stoking science denial, or should we be blaming big business, which, for example, has misled the public regarding climate change and cigarettes, you know, just to name a few examples? Yeah. Naomi Oreskes and Eric Conway talk about manufacturing doubt, which is an enormous issue. And most of the general public is not aware that the kind of doubt they've experienced about whether tobacco causes cancer or whether climate change is human cause was doubt
这是我们需要帮助公众理解的东西，即这是科学的力量。我们不应该教授50年前的科学。那么，回到媒体，你会说当涉及到煽动科学否认主义时，他们是最大的问题吗？还是我们应该责怪大企业，例如，它们在气候变化和香烟方面误导了公众，你知道，仅举几个例子？是的，娜奥米·奥雷斯克斯和埃里克·康威谈到了制造怀疑，这是一个巨大的问题。大多数普通大众并不知道他们所经历的那种关于烟草是否致癌或气候变化是否是人为造成的怀疑，是
that was manufactured by corporations that hired public relations firms to try to increase the doubt so that people wouldn't think, oh, I shouldn't smoke anymore, or I probably should buy an electric car or whatever. I should keep putting fuel in my tank because nobody knows for sure yet. So the kind of doubt that has been brewing in a lot of these fields was done by PR firms. And some of the same PR firms worked for RJ Reynolds and then for Exxon. And we need to be deeply suspicious of those sorts of things. I mean, we talk about denial, doubt, and resistance in our book, but we want people to stay skeptical. Skepticism is a healthy thing and that's something that's embedded in the scientific process. We should be very skeptical when we find out who
由企业制造的，这些企业雇佣了公关公司试图增加怀疑，这样人们就不会想，哦，我不应该再吸烟了，或者我可能应该买一辆电动汽车什么的。我应该继续给油箱加油，因为还没有人能确定。所以很多这些领域中酝酿的怀疑是由公关公司制造的。一些相同的公关公司曾为雷诺烟草公司工作，后来又为埃克森美孚工作。我们需要对这类事情保持高度怀疑。我的意思是，我们在书中谈到了否认、怀疑和抵触，但我们希望人们保持怀疑态度。怀疑是一种健康的事情，这是嵌入在科学过程中的。当我们发现是谁时，我们应该非常怀疑
funded those kind of endeavors that keep us doubtful. So what are some of the psychological factors that lead to science denial? I mean, I think that what we're talking about is people are picking and choosing the things that they want to hear or believe in? So one of the things we've looked at are the cognitive biases that people have. And many listeners here will be familiar with confirmation bias, for example. So this is an implicit bias that leads us to attend to, remember, recall, those things that already align with the things that we believe. And it's very easy for all of us to think that we do that, to know that we do that.
资助了那些让我们保持怀疑的努力。那么导致科学否认主义的一些心理因素是什么？我的意思是，我认为我们所谈论的是人们在挑选他们想听或想相信的东西？所以我们研究的事情之一是人们拥有的认知偏见。这里的许多听众会熟悉确认偏见，例如。所以这是一种隐含的偏见，导致我们关注、记住、回忆那些已经与我们所相信的东西相一致的事情。我们所有人很容易认为我们这样做，知道我们这样做。
So one of the things we try to do in the book is not make this an us and them kind of argument that, you know, we, none of us deny science, but everybody else does. The issue is that we all have these cognitive biases. So you can think about the next time that you're searching for something that you want to know. And if you already have an idea about what you'd like to find and what you believe, and you stop searching once you find confirmation of what you believe, that's confirmation bias. And what Daniel Connaman talks about, the Nobel Prize winning psychologist who wrote Thinking Fast and Slow, he talks about System 1 and System 2, you know, that when we do System 1 thinking, we're being quick and impulsive. And when we do System 2 thinking, we're slower, more rational, more analytical, more thoughtful. And we need to know when to employ System 2 thinking. We need to know when to slow down. If you're searching for where to get Thai food tomorrow, big deal. That might not matter. System 1 would be fine. But System 2, when you're trying to decide whether to inject dewormer to cure your COVID case, you might want to dig a little deeper.
所以我们在书中尝试做的事情之一是不要把它变成一种我们和他们的争论，你知道，我们，我们没有人否认科学，但其他人却否认。问题在于我们都有这些认知偏见。所以你可以想想下次当你搜索你想知道的东西时。如果你已经对你想找到的东西和你所相信的东西有了一个想法，并且当你找到你所相信的东西的确认时就停止搜索，那就是确认偏见。丹尼尔·卡尼曼谈到了，那位写了《思考，快与慢》的诺贝尔奖心理学家，他谈到了系统1和系统2，你知道，当我们进行系统1思考时，我们是快速和冲动的。而当我们进行系统2思考时，我们更慢、更理性、更分析、更深思熟虑。我们需要知道何时使用系统2思考。我们需要知道何时慢下来。如果你在搜索明天去哪里吃泰国菜，大不了。那可能没关系。系统1就可以了。但系统2，当你试图决定是否注射驱虫药来治愈你的新冠病例时，你可能想深入挖掘一下。
So that's one of many that we talk about. Another psychological process our listeners will be familiar with is motivated reasoning. So in motivated reasoning, are you reasoning towards accuracy conclusions, conclusions that are accurate, or are you reasoning towards a desired conclusion? And this is where you can help yourself by evoking system two processes. So you can stop and you can think, well, I want it to be true that eating chocolate for breakfast will make me lose weight. So am I evaluating the evidence in this study fairly and objectively to get an accurate
所以这是我们谈到的许多偏见之一。我们的听众会熟悉的另一个心理过程是动机性推理。所以，在动机性推理中，你是朝着准确的结论，即准确的结论进行推理，还是朝着期望的结论进行推理？这就是你可以通过唤起系统2过程来帮助自己的地方。所以你可以停下来，你可以想，嗯，我希望吃早餐吃巧克力能让我减肥是真的。所以我是在公平客观地评估这项研究中的证据以获得准确的
conclusion or am I all in on putting some Nutella on my toes? Another factor which will not surprise anyone is social identity. That has become just deeply pronounced in recent months in light of COVID, as we all know. But the ways in which we are all tribal creatures, we all are thinking about what our group believes, and we tend to align with people who have similar values and beliefs. And social identity drives a lot of what's going on right now, rather than going deeply into System 2 and thinking about, well, should I actually believe what others believe?
结论，还是我完全沉迷于在脚趾上涂抹能多益？另一个不会让任何人感到惊讶的因素是社会认同。正如我们所知，鉴于新冠疫情，这一点在最近几个月变得非常明显。但我们都是部落生物，我们都在思考我们的群体相信什么，我们倾向于与拥有相似价值观和信念的人保持一致。社会认同驱动了现在发生的很多事情，而不是深入到系统2并思考，嗯，我真的应该相信别人所相信的吗？
It's a kind of impulsive reaction to think this is what my tribe thinks, this is what I think, and I'm not going to go against that. And so we've seen people recently, there was a story in Missouri that people were wearing disguises in order to go get vaccinated. And I see that that cropped up again in Italy this week. That was in the news, that it's even happening there, that people don't want other people to know they're getting vaccinated because their tribe is not getting vaccinated and is opposed. And our social psychologist listeners will know about persuasion and how in-group members are more persuasive. So this is something you can turn around. So in our book, we don't just talk about the challenges. We talk about potential ways to address these challenges. So you can turn the social identity around by trying to have trusted in-group members of a community talk about vaccinations and
这是一种冲动的反应，认为这就是我的部落所想的，这就是我所想的，我不会违背这一点。所以我们最近看到人们，密苏里州有一个故事，人们为了去接种疫苗而乔装打扮。我看到这周在意大利又出现了这种情况。新闻里报道了，甚至在那里也发生了，人们不想让别人知道他们正在接种疫苗，因为他们的部落没有接种疫苗并且反对。我们的社会心理学家听众会了解说服力，以及群体内成员如何更具说服力。所以这是你可以扭转的事情。所以在我们的书中，我们不仅谈论挑战。我们谈论解决这些挑战的潜在方法。所以你可以通过尝试让社区中值得信赖的群体内成员谈论疫苗接种来扭转社会认同，并且
Arbor and I have shared that we've seen church leaders, pastors, talk about vaccination, and then have a vaccination tent outside the church after services so that you can get your vaccine right there from people in your community that you trust. So you can also leverage these identity values and identity persuasion techniques we know as social psychologists to communicate more effectively about. about the science. And I think that connects to some of the ideas we talk about in terms of epistemic cognition. If you think about epistemic authorities, we all have more than one epistemic authority in our lives. It's not just that we listen to one particular radio commentator
芭芭拉和我分享过，我们看到教会领袖、牧师谈论疫苗接种，然后在礼拜后在教堂外设立疫苗接种帐篷，这样你就可以直接从你信任的社区成员那里接种疫苗。所以你也可以利用这些作为社会心理学家所知的身份价值观和身份说服技巧，更有效地沟通。关于科学。我认为这与我们谈论的关于认知认识论的一些想法有关。如果你考虑认知权威，我们每个人的生活中都有不止一个认知权威。不仅仅是我们听某个特定的广播评论员
who might be giving us ideas or one TV broadcaster, but we do have pastors and doctors and other sorts of people who we trust. And so one of my family members who didn't want to get vaccinated, I was unable to fully persuade because he kept saying, but I have all these underlying conditions. And I'm just afraid to get the vaccine. I think it'll make it worse. And I said, okay, why don't you talk to your doctor? The next day, he talked to his doctor and his doctor said,
他可能给我们提供想法，或者某个电视广播员，但我们确实有牧师、医生和其他我们信任的人。所以我的一个不想接种疫苗的家庭成员，我无法完全说服，因为他一直说，但我有所有这些潜在的疾病。我只是害怕接种疫苗。我认为这会让情况变得更糟。我说，好吧，你为什么不和你的医生谈谈？第二天，他和他医生谈了，他的医生说，
oh, it's because you have these underlying conditions that you need to get vaccinated. So he immediately did it. But we have to figure out when we converse with other people about these things, who else is it that they trust? Who can we refer them to? And the people who are those epistemic authorities need to. step up and recognize the role that they can play in a community. Another one of the really interesting terms that you use in the book is cafeteria denial.
哦，正是因为你有这些潜在的疾病，你才需要接种疫苗。所以他立刻就做了。但当我们与其他人谈论这些事情时，我们必须弄清楚他们还信任谁？我们可以把他们推荐给谁？那些作为认知权威的人需要站出来，认识到他们可以在社区中发挥的作用。你在书中使用的另一个非常有趣的术语是自助餐式否认。
So where people pick and choose what science are going to believe and disbelieve, what is the psychological explanation behind that? And to cafeteria deniers even know that's what they're doing? Well, cafeteria denial is when you pick and choose which parts of science you want to believe, those people who go to the flat earth convention probably fly in probably are there tweeting about it on their cell phone. So they're certainly not denying all of technology and science in our advanced civilization, but they are choosing this one particular thing to deny. And I think some of the psychological explanations there are motivated reasoning. Of course, we just discussed, and identity.
所以人们挑选他们要相信和不相信的科学，这背后的心理学解释是什么？自助餐式否认者甚至知道他们在做什么吗？嗯，自助餐式否认是指你挑选你想相信的科学部分，那些去地平说大会的人可能飞过去，可能正在用手机发推文。所以他们当然没有否认我们先进文明中的所有技术和科学，但他们选择了这一个特定的东西来否认。我认为这里的一些心理学解释是动机性推理。当然，我们刚刚讨论过，还有认同。
which we just discussed. There's a new book out by Lee McIntyre who went to a flat earth convention and he wrote a book about how to talk to science deniers. And he found when he was there that it's really a social group for them. And it's people that they can relate to. So again, identity plays in heavily when we cafeteria deny. And this happens on every side. of the political spectrum, too. It's worth noting. So you can think about the mother's groups that
我们刚刚讨论过。李·麦金太尔写了一本新书，他去参加了一个地平说大会，他写了一本关于如何与科学否认者交谈的书。他在那里发现，这对他们来说确实是一个社交群体。这是他们可以产生共鸣的人。所以再次，当我们进行自助餐式否认时，认同发挥了很大作用。这种情况发生在政治光谱的每一边。值得注意的是。所以你可以想想那些母亲群体
have not vaccinated their children because they believe in doing only things that are absolutely natural for their kids. These are women who had home births and then who breastfed and then talk to each other about why they should delay vaccinations or not do them at all. And yet, these are people who firmly believe in science in many other ways. But this is a choice they've made regarding their social identity again to deny the role of vaccinations. And we also know stories of people who have changed their minds in those groups. I think everybody knows somebody like that. But there was a yoga teacher in my community who made the decision not to vaccinate
没有给孩子接种疫苗，因为她们相信只为孩子做绝对自然的事情。这些女性进行了家庭分娩，然后进行了母乳喂养，然后互相讨论为什么她们应该推迟疫苗接种或根本不接种。然而，这些人坚定地相信其他许多方面的科学。但这又是她们为了社会认同而做出的选择，以否认疫苗接种的作用。我们也知道那些群体中改变主意的人的故事。我想每个人都认识这样的人。但我社区里有一位瑜伽老师做出了不接种疫苗的决定
her child because none of her mother in group friends were. And then when her child was nine, she met a mother who had an immunocompromised child who said, this is just not fair. My kid can't even go to school around your kids because they'll die if they get the measles. And the woman just thought about it and thought, I can't be so selfish. This is terrible I've been doing this. And went out and vaccinated her kid at nine the next day, went to the doctor and got the childhood vaccination. So people can be turned around in those things. It's not that we're permanently denying all the things like that. There are many ways to open ourselves up and to open each other up to new points of view.
她的孩子，因为她的母亲群体朋友都没有接种。然后当她的孩子九岁时，她遇到了一位有免疫功能低下孩子的母亲，她说，这太不公平了。我的孩子甚至不能在你的孩子周围上学，因为如果他们得了麻疹，他们就会死。那个女人只是想了想，心想，我不能这么自私。我一直在做这件事太可怕了。于是第二天就去给孩子接种了疫苗，去了医生那里接种了儿童疫苗。所以人们在这些事情上是可以被扭转的。并不是说我们永久地否认所有这些事情。有很多方法可以让我们敞开心扉，并让彼此接触到新的观点。
So your book includes examples of organizations that promulgate unfounded information. say about vaccinations for children, as we were just discussing. And they look very much like evidence-based information from the scientific establishment. So what do you tell non-scientists who are trying to understand whether what they're looking at is good science or bad science? How do you know if you're a lay person? I think part of what we have to do is steer people to good sources. And one of the things that we do want to make clear is this isn't just an individual problem, there are bigger solutions out there. And so big tech is highly responsible for a lot of what happens that we were talking about with algorithms. But they're also responsible for solutions. And one of
所以你的书中包含了宣传毫无根据的信息的组织例子。比如关于儿童疫苗接种，正如我们刚才讨论的那样。它们看起来非常像来自科学机构的基于证据的信息。那么你对那些试图理解他们所看到的是好科学还是坏科学的非科学家说了什么？如果你是一个外行，你怎么知道？我认为我们必须做的一部分是引导人们找到好的来源。我们确实想明确的一点是，这不仅仅是一个个人问题，还有更大的解决方案。所以大型科技公司对我们谈论的算法所发生的很多事情负有很大责任。但它们也对解决方案负有责任。其中之一
the notable ones is that in 2019, pre-COVID, when the issue about vaccinations was childhood vaccinations and measles in particular, both Twitter and Pinterest made the decision that if you were to search for anti-vax information on either of their sites, you would be immediately directed to a list of authoritative places to go, the World Health Organization, the American Pediatric Association, the places that had reputable information. We could see way more of that. We really need for big tech to step up and figure out how to lead people to the sources that are valid and reliable. That is not that hard to do. And as you are searching, there are search strategies that you can use that are developed by psychologists and educators. My colleague,
值得注意的是，在2019年，新冠疫情前，当关于疫苗接种的问题是儿童疫苗接种，特别是麻疹时，Twitter和Pinterest都做出了决定，如果你在他们的任何网站上搜索反疫苗信息，你会被立即引导到一系列权威的地方，世界卫生组织，美国儿科学会，那些拥有可靠信息的地方。我们可以看到更多这样的情况。我们真的需要大型科技公司站出来，弄清楚如何引导人们找到有效和可靠的来源。这并不难做到。当你搜索时，有一些由心理学家和教育工作者开发的搜索策略。我的同事，
Doug Lombardi, and I have an article in educational psychologist, which is an APA Division 15 journal, which talks about search strategies. What are the strategies you can employ? And we have many members in our psychological community that have worked on this problem. And it's things like lateral reading, opening up a new window, maybe using that incognito mode so they don't know what you've already searched for, and then seeing if you can find alternative or confirming evidence, there's lots of strategies you can use, and many of us have written about that. And Sam Weinberg at Stanford has done a lot of studies with kids in elementary, high school, and college level to look at what their search strategies are and how they go about
道格·隆巴尔迪和我有一篇发表在《教育心理学家》上的文章，这是美国心理学会第15分会的期刊，讨论了搜索策略。你可以采用什么策略？我们在心理学界有很多成员致力于解决这个问题。比如横向阅读，打开一个新窗口，也许使用隐身模式，这样他们就不知道你已经搜索过什么，然后看看你是否能找到替代或确认的证据，有很多策略可以使用，我们很多人都写过关于这方面的文章。斯坦福大学的萨姆·温伯格对小学、高中和大学水平的孩子进行了很多研究，以观察他们的搜索策略以及他们如何进行
this. And they were shocked, and their findings that are really notable. and their claim was easily duped, was how they described most kids who do searches, that they do not have the kind of strategy scales talks about. And those are the things that they are creating curricula now to help students learn how to do. We need to really think hard about how schools all the way through college are helping teach these strategies repeatedly. It can't be a one-time thing. With every kind of research project, teachers have an opportunity to help kids learn better strategies. and to ferret out what the truth might be.
这件事。他们感到震惊，他们的发现非常值得注意。他们的主张是容易被愚弄，这是他们描述大多数进行搜索的孩子的方式，他们没有西纳特谈到的那种策略量表。而这些正是他们现在正在创建课程来帮助学生学习如何做的东西。我们需要真正认真思考学校从小学到大学如何帮助反复教授这些策略。这不能是一次性的事情。通过每一种研究项目，教师都有机会帮助孩子学习更好的策略。并辨别真相可能是什么。
So as you were writing the book, and as we're talking, it's clear that there are a lot of people who need the information that you're putting out there. But what audiences did you have in mind when you were working on this? I mean, were you trying to get to teachers or science journalists or policy makers or the scientists themselves or just everyday consumers of science? I mean, how could you decide who your audience was? It's so vast. Well, you just listed our audience, intended audience members. Kim, what we really wanted to do is share the psychological information, the research done by Barbara and myself, and so many people who are members of the APA who are doing research on misinformation and identity groups, motivated reasoning, cognitive biases.
所以当你们写这本书时，正如我们正在谈论的那样，很明显有很多人需要你们发布的信息。但你们在工作时想到了哪些受众？我的意思是，你们是想接触教师、科学记者、政策制定者、科学家本人，还是仅仅是科学的日常消费者？我的意思是，你们怎么能决定谁是你们的受众？这太广阔了。嗯，你刚刚列出了我们的受众，预期的受众成员。金，我们真正想做的是分享心理学信息，芭芭拉和我所做的研究，以及许多作为美国心理学会成员的人，他们正在对错误信息和认同群体、动机性推理、认知偏见进行研究。
There's so many people in psychology who are on the front lines of this endeavor in their own research. We wanted to bring that information to teachers in K through 12 in higher ed, science communicators, particularly scientists themselves. We mentioned earlier who don't always understand these issues because they haven't been trained in psychology, policymakers, journalists. So we definitely wanted to bring this information to a wide way of people that
心理学领域有许多人正站在这一努力的最前线，进行着各自的研究。我们希望将这些信息带给K-12阶段的教师、高等教育工作者、科学传播者，特别是科学家本人。我们之前提到过，由于没有受过心理学训练，他们并不总是理解这些问题，此外还有政策制定者和记者。所以我们确实希望将这些信息带给广泛的人群，
may not have access to those APA journals we all read. Well, last question. I just want to know what people can do when they find themselves in a conversation, whether it's in person or online, with a friend or a loved one or even just an acquaintance,
他们可能无法接触到我们所有人都在阅读的美国心理学会（APA）期刊。好了，最后一个问题。我只是想知道，当人们发现自己无论是在面对面还是在线上，与朋友、爱人甚至仅仅是熟人交谈时，
who's espousing anti-scientist, views on some of these hot button topics. What's the best way to engage productively in these conversations? We would encourage them to listen, above and beyond anything else, listen really well, try to find out what it is that is the basis of concern. Where did they get that information? What did they think? What are the basic values behind it? And we have stories of success with this sort of thing. I gave a public talk a couple years ago right before COVID broke out. And there was a man in the audience who asked to meet with me afterwards. We had coffee. He said, I'm one of those people you've been talking about. I don't think climate change is human cause. Bob, blah, blah, blah, blah. You know,
对方在某些热门话题上持有反科学观点，他们该怎么办？进行富有成效的对话的最佳方式是什么？我们会鼓励他们倾听，最重要的是，要真正地倾听，试着找出他们担忧的根源是什么。他们从哪里获得的信息？他们是怎么想的？背后的基本价值观是什么？我们有这类成功案例。几年前，在新冠疫情爆发前夕，我做了一次公开演讲。听众中有一位男士在会后要求见我。我们一起喝了咖啡。他说：“我就是你谈到的那种人。我不认为气候变化是人为造成的，吧啦吧啦……”你知道，
he had a whole lot of things that he did not believe in. We talked for maybe an hour and a half. And there was a point at which I thought I really need to try to connect around common values. And this this is something we can all do. Figure out what you do have in common with this person rather than the ways in which you are divided. And we seem to be about the same age. I asked if he had grandchildren. We began to talk about our grandchildren, had a lovely conversation. And I said, you know, I'm really worried about the planet that we're leaving them. Does that concern you? And he softened and melted and said, yes, I am really worried. And suddenly I realized he wasn't wholly a climate denier. He was concerned about the economics and how we were going to solve the problem. He began to talk
他有很多不相信的事情。我们谈了大约一个半小时。在某个时刻，我想我真的需要尝试围绕共同的价值观建立联系。这是我们所有人都能做到的事情。找出你与这个人共同的地方，而不是你们分歧的地方。我们看起来年龄差不多。我问他是否有孙辈。我们开始谈论我们的孙辈，进行了一次愉快的交谈。然后我说：“你知道，我真的很担心我们留给他们的星球。你担心吗？”他态度软化了，说：“是的，我真的很担心。”突然我意识到他并非完全否认气候变化。他担心的是经济问题以及我们将如何解决这个问题。他开始谈论
about that. And now we were on safe ground and we could talk about those issues. But often there is a way to reach someone if you really listen, find where you connect. And there's so many examples of people who are doing this now. We talk about Catherine Cahoe, who's the climate scientist who's an evangelical Christian as well and the way she's reached out to the evangelical community to try to to communicate about climate science. And they trust her in a way that is impressive. So I think we need more and more people like that as well. Dr. Sinatra? And as psychologists, we know that people don't often change their mind if you come into the conversation and tell them what they think is crazy or silly or stupid, that's not really the best way to promote a change in thinking. So psychologists can employ
这一点。现在我们处于安全的领域，可以讨论这些问题了。但通常情况下，如果你真的倾听，找到你们的共同点，总有一种方法可以触及对方。现在有太多人正在这样做。我们谈到了凯瑟琳·海霍（Katharine Hayhoe），她是一位气候科学家，同时也是一位福音派基督徒，她接触福音派社区以尝试传播气候科学的方式非常令人印象深刻，他们信任她。所以我认为我们也需要越来越多这样的人。西纳特拉博士？作为心理学家，我们知道，如果你在对话中告诉对方他们的想法是疯狂的、愚蠢的或荒谬的，他们通常不会改变主意，这并不是促进思维转变的最佳方式。所以心理学家可以运用
the strategies they know, empathy, understanding, connecting on a person. level, those are strategies that members of the general public can use to communicate with people who are not in full denial, but often just have questions. We talk about people in what we call them movable middle. Those are people who really are open. They're just perhaps confused. Science is very difficult to understand and very complex. They may have legitimate questions and concerns.
他们所知的策略：同理心、理解、建立个人层面的联系。这些策略普通大众也可以用来与那些并非完全否认，但通常只是有疑问的人进行沟通。我们谈论的是我们所说的“可动摇的中间派”。这些人实际上是开放的。他们可能只是感到困惑。科学非常难懂且非常复杂。他们可能有合理的疑问和担忧。
my niece was concerned when she heard that the COVID vaccine could make you infertile. That was going around the internet. And she just was concerned about that. That's a legitimate concern. So obviously she got that resolved and she got vaccinated. And then she helped a friend of hers on Facebook who'd shared that information to find out it wasn't true. And then the friend was vaccinated as well. So I think using our psychological tools of empathy and understanding our
我的侄女听说新冠疫苗会导致不孕时很担心。那条消息在互联网上传播。她只是对此感到担忧。这是一个合理的担忧。所以很明显，她解决了这个问题并接种了疫苗。然后她帮助她在Facebook上分享过该信息的朋友发现那不是真的。后来那位朋友也接种了疫苗。所以我认为运用我们心理学上的同理心和理解工具，
important ways for us to reach people who are in that movable middle. And the media tends to emphasize the flat earther or the anti-vaxxer who is very extreme. And that's not the majority of people. And I think overall, what we're trying to do is promote a scientific attitude in the general public and in the people we talk to. We want to model that. We want to promote it. We want to show what it gets us. And a scientific attitude is basically the idea that you're open to evidence and you have a willingness to change your mind based on new evidence. And I think we'd like to see that at the heart of the scientific curriculum as well as the kinds of things that each of us can go about modeling in our daily conversations. Well, this is all excellent advice. I want our listeners to know
是我们接触那些“可动摇的中间派”的重要方式。媒体倾向于强调那些非常极端的“地平论者”或“反疫苗者”。但那并不是大多数人。我认为总的来说，我们试图做的是在公众和我们交谈的对象中促进一种科学态度。我们想成为榜样。我们想推广它。我们想展示它能带来什么。科学态度基本上就是对证据持开放态度，并愿意根据新证据改变主意。我认为我们希望在科学课程的核心中看到这一点，也希望看到我们每个人在日常对话中可以效仿这种做法。好吧，这些都是极好的建议。我想让我们的听众知道，
the name of the book is Science Denial, why it happens and what to do about it. Dr. Sinatra, Dr. Hofer, thank you for joining us today. This has been really interesting. Thank you so much for having us. We really appreciate it. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology at www.combeatingof Psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, Spotify, or wherever you get your favorite podcasts. And please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology
这本书的书名是《科学否认：为什么会发生以及该怎么办》（Science Denial: Why It Happens and What to Do About It）。西纳特拉博士、霍弗博士，感谢你们今天加入我们。这真的非常有趣。非常感谢邀请我们。我们真的很感激。您可以在 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或 Apple、Stitcher、Spotify 或您获取喜爱的播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology）的往期节目。请给我们留下评论。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology
at APA.org. That's Speaking of Psychology, all one word, at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman, our sound editor. is Chris Kondyian. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
at APA.org。那是 Speaking of Psychology，连在一起，at APA.org。《心理学谈话》由李·韦纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作，我们的声音编辑是克里斯·孔迪安（Chris Kondyian）。感谢您的收听。代表美国心理学会，我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。